Let's go next to our caller from the eight
four seven area code who's calling today from
eight four seven.
David, it's you, I agree.
I'm a proud new member, and I'm so happy to
be talking to you.
Love the show.
Thank you, Eli.
I appreciate that.
So couple things that I want actually help
answer for your last caller, OK?
On the public, my kids are 13 and 11 in the
school system.
Just send out something saying we have the
option to keep them home.
There are maybe only certain days that go
to school or there maybe you're learning only
options.
So I don't even know that they're necessarily
going to open the public school.
What what what state is this?
Any lie?
Where are you located?
I'm in the Chicago suburbs.
OK.
Got it.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, I think that this is much
like with the shut downs, which is Donald
Trump likes to pretend that he's the boss
and he tells the 50 states what to do.
But these are decisions that are probably
going to vary dramatically between states
and even within states.
I imagine that there will be parts of states
and school districts that say we're going
to do this or we're going to do that.
The idea that Trump is going to be running
the decisions for all of these school districts
is a fantasy.
Yes, pretty much.
I think Governor Pritzker here is doing a
wonderful job, and that's why they monitor
it.
So in case they need to pull back, they're
not going to put anyone at risk, especially
my family.
We all have as well, unfortunately.
Yeah.
And then the other thing I was going to say
about the economy thing is he's calling Forbes
magazine and on Musk is kind of pushing it
here and he's trying to call his party the
birthday party and claiming if you get a vaccine
for corona virus, it's the mark of the beast.
So I don't think he's going
to be getting anybody to vote for him.
Yeah, yeah.
Conures comments about vaccines were crazy.
But but to get back to something that's much
more relevant, though, than Konya.
So what if what is you.
Have you decided your kids aren't going into
school or what?
What or are you going to wait to see what
the school district decides?
I have a feeling what's going to end up coming
down of the district is, you know, they're
very aware of children with allergies or autoimmune
diseases that it's going to come down to.
They're going to do a risk assessment from
the top down and recommend to parents or maybe
mandated saying you're child's probably should
be in an e-learning situation or a remote
learning situation versus coming in because
it's too dangerous for them.
I don't think they show you why you think
that.
They may say certain kids will come in but
will have fewer people in the classroom by
taking kids with with conditions that may
make them more at risk.
And they can do e-learning.
I have a I have a feeling that's where it's
headed.
Interesting.
All right.
Well, listen.
My.
Yeah.
Oh, David.
I was just actually coming last to call her.
My main question was actually about what you
had said when you were talking about being
Black Lives Matter.
Jason.
I'm Jewish, too.
And Terry Cruz was trying to get into it with
Don Lemon.
But nobody is really letting anybody talk
about what the founders of the movement, the
actual doctrine is.
So I don't know why they're just not letting
people know and understand that, yeah, there
is good people in the movement.
But I don't think people understand what is
being dictated from top down or what the ultimate
goals are.
Yeah.
And again, we you can argue the top down doesn't
matter because it's a it's sort of a leaderless
organization.
But the point the point I've made before is
there's a lot of individual Black Lives Matter
groups saying, you know this we've got to
fight against Jewish supremacy in the Israeli
Palestinian conflict than our battle is the
same battle that the Palestinians are fighting.
It's like, listen, check out my clips about
the Israeli Palestinian conflict.
You will find that that I have the measured
take on what is going on.
But it is not the same battle.
There's a lot of anti-Semitism within Black
Lives Matter and the women's march, which
we talked about previously.
And so I'm right there about structural racism
in the United States.
I'm right there about all of these different
issues.
But to say this is this is the same battle
the Palestinians are fighting against Israelis,
it's like, no, it's not.
And you're going to lose a lot of people if
people are paying attention.
You're going to lose a lot of people with
that argument.
Yeah.
They just don't understand the history of
the conflict and how it's been going on.
Absolutely.
Way, way, way too long.
But I just want to say thank you for everything
you do.
I keep telling everybody, check out the show
and join like I did.
Please.
I mean, I'm going out of work.
Contractor for instructions on education.
However, I can definitely afford with the
discount to get your show on the air and keep
keep it going.
Thank you.
You're a great job.
And we love watching you every day, man.
Eli, I appreciate it.
Say hi to everybody there in the Chicago area
and hope it all works out with the school
year.
Yes.
And you take care, stay safe, happy, healthy,
and keep up the good work for the show, it's
amazing.
All right.
Thank you very much.
And an early Shabbat shalom, my friend.
Thank you so much.
OK, let's go next to our caller from the nine
one four area code.
Who's calling today from nine one four?
Hi, this is Brian.
Did you say Ryan?
Yeah, hi.
So, Mike, my question is about the Lincoln
Project.
I'm sorry if you've already covered it on
the show and I just missed it.
But there's this group, the Lincoln Project,
that's putting out ads, and I think they're
really, really effective.
And I was wondering if you had any comments
on them.
You seen them?
Yeah.
So Lincoln Project is anti Trump Republicans.
It includes Kellyanne Conway's husband, George
Conway.
I believe Steve Schmidt, former McCain adviser,
is involved.
Rick Wilson, who's been a guest on this program,
longtime Republican strategist as well.
There's a bunch of others, but those are like
the three big ones.
Am I right?
I actually don't know a lot about the causation.
Well, in any case, they've been producing
anti Trump ads.
I mean, listen, the ads are very good.
I don't know.
You know, when I see the ad, it reinforces
the beliefs I already have.
But I don't know if it's changing any minds,
so to speak.
But to the extent that they have money and
these are Republicans who recognize the danger
of Donald Trump, it's great.
The ads are very good.
And we've reviewed a couple of them on the
program before.
Yeah, and I just wanted to point out a particular
ad that I thought was it blew my mind is I've
never seen anything like it.
Yeah.
There was one ad called Whispers that the
name of it on the YouTube video.
And it seems like whispers is intended just
to be seen by Donald Trump.
And it's just meant to throw him into tilt.
Did you see that ad, which is a really crazy
ass?
I think that actually, you know, I mentioned
before, I don't know how many minds are being
changed by these ads.
I actually think you're on to something, which
is the ads are very well calibrated to trigger
Donald Trump himself.
And he has gone on tweet storms as a result
of not always the ad itself, but the fallout
from these ads.
And that, I think, is actually a really clever
aspect to it, because a lot of the damage
that has Trump has suffered has been self-inflicted
damage.
Like nobody said, he had to fail on Corona.
He could have taken it seriously.
It was to some degree self-inflicted, not
the virus.
The virus would have been here either way.
But Trump's reaction.
So I think the ads are good in that and in
that way that they trigger Trump.
Yeah, yeah, it's.
I've never seen it before.
We've never seen anything like what we're
seeing before.
All right, my friend, thank you so much for
the call.
I appreciate it.
We are in uncharted territory.
I think is the way I would put it.
Thanks to everybody who called in was just
taking a few brief phone calls.
But I do want to go to a break because the
news has just broken about the Supreme Court
decision on Donald Trump's taxes.
And that's what I'm going to talk about right
after this short break.